hello
i am constantine and i'm going to talk
about multi-channel bayesian persuasion
this is a joint work of jakob babichenko
in battleground gohan and havankshu
there are many real-life examples in
which a very informed company or person
aims to influence the behavior of a
group of people
by statistically revealing some
information
one such example is a politician trying
to persuade voters
a standard mathematical model capturing
this situation and many others
is bayesian persuasion
in the bayesian persuasion model
there is an agent called sender for
example a politician
who aims to persuade some set of agents
called receivers
for example voters
to act in the sender's favor
both the sender
and each of the receivers
have some utility function and the
utility functions need not to be aligned
between the agents
they assume that there is a certain
value called state
which is known to the sender but not to
the receivers
it might be for example the plan of the
politician
however they assume that there is a
common knowledge prior distribution on
the values of this state
the sender strategically commits to some
information elevation policy which we
call the signaling scheme
before observing the true value of the
state
the current literature on bayesian
persuasion
mostly assumes a dichotomy between two
extreme settings
in one such setting the sender can
communicate via a separate private
channel with each of the receivers
unsurprisingly the setting is called
private persuasion
the second extreme
in which
the sender must send the same signal to
each of the receivers this is public
persuasion
however in many real-life situations it
is natural to assume that the sender can
communicate with different subsets of
receivers
using different channels
and this is the setting we study
such channels may be specified for
example
by
groups in social media or by billboards
let's illustrate our setting through an
example
in this example we have three states
and the probabilities of them are
0.3.5 and 0.2
we have a center and four receivers
we also have three communication
channels
the red channel is observed by the first
two receivers
the purple channel is observed by the
last three receivers
and the green channel is absorbed by
receivers 2 and 3.
first of all
the sender should commit to a signal in
schemes sigma
the stimulated scheme is a randomized
function from the space of the states
to a certain
space of
signals
in other words for every possible state
the cigarette scheme specifies the fresh
probability
to send which combination of signals via
the different communication channels
upon committee to the signaling scheme
the true state is drawn according to the
prior distribution and is reported to
the sender
then at this true value of the state
together of the cigarette scheme
specify
which signals are sent
via the communication channels
each receiver sees
the signals
which
correspond to the communication channels
that she absorbs
in our example receiver one observes
only the red communication channel and
therefore she only sees the signal sigma
one
on the other hand the second receiver
observes all three communication
channels and therefore she learns sigma
1 sigma 2 and sigma 3.
upon observing the relevant signals
each receiver uses a biases law to
update her belief about the distribution
of the state
from the prior distribution to a certain
posterior distribution
and then each receiver takes a certain
action aiming to maximize her expected
utility
over the posterior distribution
note that the utility of each agent
may depend on the true value of the
state as well as on the actions of all
the receivers
that is they allow externalities between
the receivers
meaning that the utility of some
receiver
is specified not only by the true state
and her own action
but probably also by the actions of the
other receivers
note that in this setting the designer
is the sender so the only freedom
is the standards choice of the signaling
scheme
and therefore
as the standard and the basic persuasion
literature
we mostly focus on the sender's point of
view
specifically the sender wishes to
maximize her expected utility over the
civilian
and the goal of us as the researchers
is to help the sender to find such a
utility maximizing signaling scheme
but this is a standard assumption in the
basal persuasion
the distinguishing property of other
work
is that we studied the most general
persuasion setting a referentary
communication channel structure prior
distribution and utilities of the sender
as well as the receivers
before presenting our main result
let's introduce a simple
mathematical formalization
which describes the structure of the
communication channels
suppose we have k receivers and then
communication channel
then we define the communication
structure
to be a binary matrix
in which each row represents another
receiver and each column represents
another communication channel
and the
each entry of this matrix
is one if and only if
the corresponding receiver observe the
corresponding communication channel
consider an example with six receivers
and four communication channels
so
the communication structure is a binary
matrix with six rows and the four
columns
and the
the first communication channel is the
the black channel it is observed by
receivers 1.3 and therefore in the first
column
the first three entries are once and the
others are zeros
the second communication channel is the
right one and so the second column
contains a
ones in the first the fourth and the
sixth entry and the others are zeros
the store the
communication channel which is the
purple one is observed by receivers 2 5
and 6
valet the fourth and the last
communication channel is observed by
receivers 3 4 and 5.
the main question we study in this work
is under which conditions
one communication structure is better
for the sender than the other
in the robust sense and robustness here
means that the cell's preferences should
hold
regardless of her own utility function
as well as the receiver's utility
functions and the power distribution
note that a discretion is related to a
previous work of glypherty and perego
who study a similar question in a
slightly different setting
for a fixed communication structure
we can define a partial ordering among
the receivers
via the relation of information
domination
we say that a receiver is information
dominated by those receivers
who observe at least the same
communication channels
in this example
a receiver number one uh observes only
the right communication channel
and the the second receiver also absorbs
uh the red the communication channel and
therefore receiver 1 is information
domain by receiver 2.
also note that in this example receiver
2
is not information dominated by any
other receiver
because she is the only receiver
observing all three communication
channels
note that the information dominance
relation
defines a partial ordering
among communication structures
intuitively
the less
information dominating pairs in in terms
of a set containment
the information structure has
the better for the sender because the
the sender has more flexibility when
implementing the signaling scheme
and it turns out
that
when they formalize this intuition
they get a necessary and sufficient
condition
uh for uh
one communication structure to be better
for the center than the other in the
robust sense
specifically it turns out and this is
our main result
that a communication structure m1 is
really better for the sender than
another communication structure m2
regardless of the prior distribution and
the utility functions of both the sender
and the receivers
if and only if every information domain
pair
in m1 is also an information magic pair
in m2
for example let's consider such
communication structures that don't
contain information dominating pairs at
all
arguably the simplest one is private
persuasion
so
each receiver has
her own private communication channel
and definitely
no receiver information dominates
another receiver
it follows from our main result
that since in parallel persuasion there
are no information domagic pairs
it is the best possible communication
structure for the sender
however it is totally unsurprising
because this is the most flexible
setting for the sender
the much more surprising cavalry
is that any information structure
without information dominating pairs of
receivers
is equivalent to private persuasion in
terms of optimal expected descenders
utility
if we go back to our example uh from a
few slides ago
uh with a six receivers and four
communication channels
then we can see that it doesn't contain
information dometic pairs of receivers
because i remind you that
in the table representing the
communication structure
each row represents
which
communication channels are absorbed by a
specific receiver and we can see that in
this example
no row dominates another row
so this communication structure is
equivalent to private persuasion
and in some sense it is better
than the naive implementation of private
persuasion
because it requires only four
communication channels rather than six
in the even implementation of private
persuasion
continuing in a similar flavor
we
can deduce from our main result
then the sender can implement travel
persuasion
using a number of channels which is only
logarithmic in the number of receivers
which is an exponential improvement
upon the naive implementation of private
persuasion using a separate channel
for each receiver
and moreover
other construction
matches the information theoretical
lower bound
of the number of channels required to
implement the private persuasion
regardless
of the utility functions and the prior
distribution
as for the proof of our main result
it
is highly inspired by cryptography
and more specifically
by a secret sharing protocols
at high level
suppose that
at a certain communication structure
the sender can implement a certain
signaling scheme
then
if we remove some information the
magnetic pairs from the communication
structure
the sender still can implement
this signaling scheme
using encryption
let's demonstrate it uh in an example
so here we have a five receivers
and suppose that the sender wishes to
transmit a private message sigma to the
first receiver
as we shall
see in a few seconds
a receiver one is not information
dominated by any other receiver and
therefore if the theorem is true it
should be doable
and uh let's assume that the signal is a
number between zero and one
so uh let's give a try uh by a sending a
via the purple communication channel
a
a message to the first receiver
so another problem is that
receivers 2 3 and 4 would also observe
this message because they share the
purple communication channel the first
receiver
and the to overcome this obstacle
the sender should pick
three uh encryption keys which are iad
uniform numbers between zero and one
one encryption key a pair a receiver
sharing the purple communication channel
with the first receiver
and then rather than transmitting sigma
itself
using the purple channel the center
should transmit a sigma plus the sum of
the encryption keys modulo 1
via the purple channel
then the sender should
look for a communication channel which
is observed by the first receiver but
not by the second one
which must exist if indeed the first
receiver is not information dominated by
the second one
and in our case
indeed such a channel exists and it is
the red channel the sender should use
the red communication channel to
transmit
the encryption key e2
the second step is looking for
a communication channel observed by
receiver one but not by receiver three
which must exist if receiver one is not
information dominated by receiver 3 and
indeed such a channel exists and it is a
the green channel
and the the sender should send the key
e3 via the green channel
and finally the red channel is absorbed
by a receiver one but not by receiver
four
and the the sender should use a direct
channel to a transmit the key for
receiver one
learns both a sigma plus two plus three
plus e4 module one and also each one of
the encryption keys e2 e3 and d4
and therefore
she can
decrypt the private message sigma on the
other hand
each of the other receivers
doesn't
learn at least one of these messages
just by construction each one of the
receivers but the first one
just sees some iid uniform numbers
between zero and one and so she learns
nothing
and therefore this methodology is
equivalent to sending a private message
to the first receiver
the proof of theorem one
in general is much more technically
involved
in particular because
we must deal
with externalities between receiver and
to overcome it
we use a harsanni's universal type space
but
at a high level
the proof is based on the same simple
idea
now let's discuss other algorithmic
results starting with the positive
result
uh in this result
we
consider
the so-called forest communication
structures
and what does it mean
as i have already mentioned
the information dominance relation
introduces a partial ordering among the
receivers
and
let's build a directed graph
on the set of receivers
by
introducing an edge
between two receivers which are
consecutive in this partial ordering
if the resultant graph is the forest
then we say that we have a forest
communication structure
continuing with this assumption that we
have a forest communication structure
where strict attention only a two
additive centers utilities
because this special case is already
interesting
that is a we assume that
the receivers have no externalities
and the one can separate generous
utility function
to a case a month
each one of which only depends on the
information that the sender reveals to
the corresponding receiver and we
introduce the regularity assumption
that each sumand is interlibrates
continuous or piecewise constant
before they are only focused on a
constant number of states
because it is well known that for a
general number of states even for public
bayesian persuasion
it is hard to approximate the optimal
cellular utility even for additive
centers utility function
under these assumptions
we provide an additive fp task for the
optimal center stimulant scheme
the proof of this result
relies on the notion of mean preserving
spreads
which is the relation between
probability distributions
we say that
one distribution is a mean preserving
spread of another
if it can be obtained from the original
distribution
by repeating the following process uh
take
some probability mass at the
distribution
and
split it between
other
points
in a way that
the weighted average of the new points
is the original point
for example
if we have a distribution on a segment
on the real line a stunning
0.8 probability must to the left point
and
0.2 probability mass to the right point
then we can get a mean preserving spread
of it
by uh splitting the 0.8 mass on the left
point
to two equal amounts and moving each
amount
by
equal distances to either side of this
point
because in this way
the weighted average of the new two
points would be trivially equal to the
original point with the 0.8 probability
mass assigned
now back to the proof of the
positive algorithmic result
very interested in finding a nice
characterization of marginal
distributions over posteriors
of all the receivers
that
are possible to the sender to implement
by signaling scheme
and by nice characterization i mean
necessary and sufficient conditions
which are specified by linear
constraints
because once we have such a
characterization
we can discretize the problem and
solve a linear program
and a previous work of brooks at al
provides such a characterization and
this characterization uses a mean
preserving spread
specifically
it is necessary as sufficient
for a set of marginal distributions over
posteriors of the receivers to be
implementable as a civilian scheme
if and only if
when we take a more informed and the
less informed the receiver in terms of
information dominance
and the require
that
the marginal distribution over
posteriors
of the more informed receiver
would be a mean preserving spread of the
marginal distribution of the lesson from
the receiver
in this way we can get a linear program
and solve it
now let's discuss a negative algorithmic
result
which holds uh even for two states
and the
receivers only having two actions and
the fourth externalities
first let's describe
standard and a simple standards utility
function family
called super majority functions
a super majority function
gets a the value of one
if the number of receivers taking a
certain action is the bubba sort of
threshold and zero otherwise
for example a simple majority is a super
majority function
we generalize this class of centers
utilities
by defining a partition of the set of
receivers
and setting
a separate super majority function
on each
element of this partition
then we take a weighted average
of a
all the super majority functions
we defined on the partition elements and
we call this faded average
a separable super majority function
it can be easily shown a using a
well-known results on bayesian
persuasion
that both public persuasion and private
persuasion
is computationally tractable for
separable super majority centers
utilities
however we show that unless peak was in
p
one cannot find in time a polynomial the
number of receivers
for a general communication structure
the optimal centers expected utility uh
when the the center's utility is a
separable super majority function
so
in general
multi-channel persuasion is
combinationally harder than both private
and public persuasion
the main takeaway from our paper
is the full characterization of a
partial ordering over all possible
communication structures
according to a robust center's
preferences
the robustness means that the
preferences are regardless of sender's
own utilities
as well as the utilities of the
receivers and the power distribution
it is interesting to study in depth
the connection of our model to various
three life situations
we provide both a positive and a
negative algorithmic result
for a special cases
but definitely there are more
interesting special cases
worth studying
one specific setting
is a fixing
utilities
for the sender and the receivers and
some power distribution
and providing the sender with a certain
uh communication structure
but allowing the sender some freedom
in performing changes to this structure
right for example one may allow the
sender
to add a limited number of communication
channel
initial question is whether it's
computationally tractable
to find the optimal in the center's
point of view a outcome of such a
setting thank you very much for your
attention